how's it going read my limit Burpo you
bros wanted more spore and I'm like
alright I'll play the morph written this
is my personal one we're gonna create a
new one we're unfortunately we're gonna
have to go from the beginning cuz
apparently you can't [ __ ] use the
ones from penis I don't I don't know
these are so simple oh well oh well
let's create something you know that you
can be proud of
oh well you know what let's give this
Beauty a couple legs and I don't know
about you bros but I always want to have
legs in my dick so you know let's go
with that okay
now this is us this is that yes this
makes sense
now we can't give him all the cool stuff
I don't know why you have to like evolve
him and [ __ ] what is he doing here what
is this what in the [ __ ] name what the
hell just happened
damn what the how can even okay I can
work with this that's but it's beautiful
ah now this is too normal for my face
okay there we go
and we give him his mouth
I guess this little thing is his mouth
uh why does he have it on his ears
because you know what nothing says I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you like it when you
have mouth on your ears okay so this is
Professor [ __ ] sense son that would
thicken sense son
there we go Dickinson sense okay
whatever
and it's beautiful I don't know I guess
we're gonna have to progress him
eventually you changed him during the
course of this gameplay my name of the
planet the bro world yeah yeah it's all
about the proud okay there we go
yes hey it's drowning what the [ __ ] get
up that yeah yeah get up get up on land
brah
how the hell does he walk anyway it's
like they're like what the [ __ ] are
those things alright so a new day has
dawned or whatever okay uh professor
Dagon said you we must make our go
professor naked said I like how his
penis is dangling while he runs fair
alright so we must kill other people and
that's how we have all these peer mother
[ __ ] the professor Dickinson does not
play games you just want to [ __ ] you
who the hell is that yeah I'm professor
Jacobsen Cal ABS oh yeah forgot how you
fight there we go
just like these little things [ __ ]
yes no no professor deck instead he
became a balloon and he needs eyes yes
where's your his eyes B I guess here oh
my god you're so pretty
yeah oh yeah gal me yes
no Deacon said you need to kill them
they are your enemy Oh beautiful oh oh
it's us what is me okay
get slap your dick on this do it revenge
[ __ ] side Oh his nose is a dick all
right spit see them eat that [ __ ] uh
they told them we could become anything
it became a triangle deck well I'm just
seeing a well well slap that [ __ ]
professor day concern well Oh what the
[ __ ] are they doing that's disgusting
what are you doing
I don't uh okay what are they doing now
are they gonna [ __ ] are the only fun so
but he's a guy
how does he it comes out of his brain I
have just got that I want that help I
don't even know anymore Bros alright so
now I can build like cool stuff and [ __ ]
it's this I don't have any points hi
who's next who's [ __ ] next professor
Dickens that shows no mercy come here
you little [ __ ]
I come from Oh Dickinson water you don't
if I can shake through that oh [ __ ] he's
winning
I'm not professionally taking some cat
loose oh no there we go yes
eat that [ __ ] it's a more while you're
at it we need to kill one more of these
[ __ ] I like how he swims yeah
the professor Dickinson has prevailed
all right we need to change the outfit I
don't like him right now
it reminds me I'm an octopus and I
[ __ ] hate octopuses they [ __ ]
freak the [ __ ] outta me
whoa professor Dickinson [ __ ] slalom
and [ __ ]
Julia all right go home and [ __ ] there
we go
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is disgusting [ __ ]
octopus sake I guess that's what they
like in Japan huh all right let's cut
the [ __ ] let's make him awesome this
is a little better but still it's a
working prop what what the [ __ ] he's an
elephant how that what the what an that
what if he would just keep him like this
cow hey yeah what the [ __ ] is oh my god
disgusting no our professor Dickinson
does not roll that way Oh
so there you go professor Dickinson I
hope you're happy you look so sad
hey don't be sad very hahahahaha yes yes
he's beautiful
I don't like angry you love it don't
deny it
alright alright let's take away this
stupid little thing hmm
let's see how he walks it's like yeah
and his mouth is in his ass it's
beautiful look at her it's like yeah
let's fix the lip I like how the feet
are like he's like a eyes like yeah
isn't it alright we're done for now I
will return soon now Jake is in his
alpha as [ __ ] man
is ugliest I don't even know anymore
okay how does he watch like I don't want
to live anymore learn how to spit Oh
what the [ __ ] man it's better whoa all
right professor Dickinson
let's go whoa yeah you go professor they
can say um Matt I Love You professor
taking said this is front by the way
alright let's go and kill some people
alright well we're still level ten so we
better keep we can charge [ __ ] hope
they don't protect each other now
they're stupid
there we go kill the baby whoa Dickinson
is happy what he uses arms okay George
motherfuckas a time deck instead there
we go there we go all right professor
dick is it no professor Dickerson has
evolved into oh my god his British
burger
Gloria I'm so happy
yeah coughed you have become smarter and
now we can keep we can hunt in a let's
kill leg
[ __ ] you egg that's right professor
Dickinson all right it's like yeah [ __ ]
yeah
all right first let me know if you want
to see more of the evolution of
professor Dickinson again a nice shy is
so shy but I give it up you enjoyed this
crack over a day and
everybody yes
I'm riding up yo no no no bad yeah I'm
just terrible here but that [ __ ]